incredibles - or tag what's your pick
for Father's Day weekend this is your
weekend ticket
[Music]
if you're looking for an empowering
superhero family comedy for Father's Day
Incredibles 2 is for you the latest from
Pixar Animation Studios is the sequel to
the first Incredibles movie which
follows the ongoing Adventures of the
par family who also happen to be
superheroes with mother and wife
Elastigirl off saving the world mr.
incredible is left taking care of the
youngest laser ice shoeing baby Jack
Jack happy Father's Day
here's dirty diapers and laser burns
sweet this movie is for you if you're a
Pixar fan you love the first Incredibles
movie or if like me you're looking for a
way to give dad a subtle hint that maybe
he should stop wearing his spandex bike
shorts around the house this incredible
cast includes notable names like Holly
Hunter Craig T nelson bob odenkirk sarah
bell and samuel l.jackson will we ever
get to see frozen's wife why is the
reason she probably looks like cardi B
if her dad is more the type to play
games like tag or pull pranks like
putting a whoopee cushion on your chair
or wake you up in the middle of the
night with a chainsaw in hockey mask the
tag is for you this weekend the couple's
gone quizzes some couples go camping
some couples go to strip clubs and have
the gang bag
and this is just what we love this is
our gangbang tag is based on a true
story of a group of friends from Spokane
Washington who played a 23 year long
game of tag although separated by life
over the years the story follows the
five main characters as they reconnect
with their annual quest to not be it
with Ed Helmes Jon Hamm Jeremy Renner
Jake Johnson and Hannibal Buress as the
group of friend tag brings an expected
level of comedy and a surprising level
of part to the big stream I think people
will be surprised at how much part there
is in the film I think ours actually
really explores kind of the themes of
friendship and and why people maintain
relationships over years and and what is
it about to be you know male friends and
all this other stuff and I think it
really will surprise you this movie is
for you if you love really smart slash
stupid physical comedy you're into
movies like wedding crashers or The
Hangover or if you're the kind of person
that thinks tagbacks are there in any
case tag a friend who needs to see this
happy Father's Day everybody that is
your weekend ticket and check back next
week for the biggest movie of the summer
oh and dad I'm sorry about the whole
don't wear spandex thing you do you
[Music]